there is concern in ukraine today that
russian forces may be attempting another
foray across the border between belarus
and ukraine with the intent of attacking
keeve a senior official in the ministry
of internal affairs says that soldiers
and vehicles have been seen near the
belarussian border with ukraine that is
a technique that has been used by the
russians to enter into ukraine in the
past there have been a continuation of
new tactics in recent days here in
ukraine everything from the missiles
which struck la viv earlier this week
attacking the airport and taking out an
aircraft repair facility to the first
use of hypersonic missiles in combat in
ukraine that was confirmed by american
authorities last night and that is the
first time that we've actually seen that
kind of technology used in this war
that's significant because those
missiles are extremely fast extremely
accurate and very hard to defend against
in fact they travel at a minimum of five
times the speed of sound the russian
government says that there's travel at
closer to ten times the speed of sound
now the russians don't have any great
anti-aircraft systems that they have to
overcome here in ukraine in order to be
able to land that kind of a missile
strike which has experts saying that
they believe that as much of a show
stopper as the use of that kind of a new
technology appears to be it may just as
much be showmanship by vladimir putin
who has been increasingly bogged down
here in ukraine looking to use a more
powerful and devastating weapon for its
psychological effects as well we'll be
bringing you the latest from here in
ukraine as it develops mercedes
stephenson global news la viv